And you might say,
well,
what's your evidence that those
differences in personality aren't
culturally constructed and the evidence
for that,
it's quite clear.
You can go online,
you look up the Scandinavian studies,
let's go online and look up gender
differences in personality
cross-culturally.
You'll find the relevant studies they've
been done with tens of thousands of
people or something she'll write clearly
is in those societies where the most is
being done to move,
move the social world into a position of
radical equality.
And so that would roughly be the
Scandinavian countries because they've
done more than that,
more of that than any other country.
The personality differences between men
and women maximize,
they don't minimize,
they maximize.
And I'll say that again in the countries
where they're most has been done to
equalize that playing field between men
and women.
Men and women get more different rather
than more of the same.
So for all your social constructionists
out there in the audience,
and there's probably not that many of
you because you wouldn't come in here
and be talked to her social
constructionist.
You're actually wrong.
Yeah.
Well,
and the thing is,
thank you,
so one of the things you might be
interested in is that it's all the same
to me.
Subsets like when I was looking into
this to begin with in this group started
probably 25 years ago,
looking at differences in personality
between men and women,
you know,
it doesn't go at all whether they were
fundamentally biological,
biological are fundamentally associate,
large boiler or mixed produced the
differences,
you know,
no one knew and the most logical
hypothesis was that as you need wise,
this society that men and women would
become more of the same,
but that is not what happened.
And so we've actually looked at social
constructionist hypothesis with regards
to gender differences in insects and
personality.
We'll put that to the test and a very
intense way and the social
constructionist viewpoint fail.
So it's very strange because no one was
already believed that,
right?
If you make this make society one of the
same in men and women get more
different.
Sorry,
what's up with that?
Well,
the answer seems to be is that there's
fundamentally two sources of variability
in personality,
right?
There's perhaps more,
but you can categorize them as roughly
genetic and roughly sociological.
Well,
if you take out all the sociological
differences between the landscape in
which men and women are raped and all
you have left are the biological and
genetic differences,
so they maximize,
well,
that's exactly what happened.
This actually matters.
It really matters and this is why that
demands for equity or so.
Well,
there's 15 reasons why demands for
equity order on this is between men and
women should not be overlooked.
Partly because it's wrong to overlook
the junior with differences between men
and women.
It's not good for the man.
It's not good for the women.
So one of the things you see in
Scandinavia,
for example,
is there's an overwhelming preponderance
female nurses and there's an
overwhelming preponderance of male
engineers and actually the data on,
on personality differences.
Um,
there's,
there's the standard traits which will
continue to go through.
I can do that quite quickly.
There's no much difference in trait
conscientiousness between men and women.
If you break it down into the aspects,
women are a bit more orderly than men,
but there's no difference in
industriousness and then with regards to
openness,
which is the intelligence,
intellect,
creativity,
dimension overall,
there's no difference between men and
women,
but if you break it up into the aspects,
then the differences are actually quite
pronounced.
So what you have is the openness to
experience is the technical trade and it
roughly breaks down into something
that's sort of like created creativity
and aesthetic interests versus the
interest in ideas and what you see is
that women are a third of the standard
deviation higher than men in terms of of
creativity and aesthetic aesthetic
proclivity,
let's say,
and men or month or the standard
deviation higher than women in terms of
interest in ideas and it's not a trivial
difference and it makes a difference.
So,
but the biggest difference between men
and women as it turns out,
and this is almost one standard
deviation,
which is a wall of indifference.
You never see that in social sciences
and massive difference is the difference
between difference in interest and the
masculine interest.
Roughly speaking is in face and the
female interest,
roughly speaking is in people and that's
what underlies the differences say in,
in,
in career choice preference between
things like nursing and psychology and
social work and that sort of thing and
engineering.
And uh,
because engineering is perhaps the most
male oriented about the disciplines and
the evidence that that's a sociological
is very,
very unique.